fleeing from the flames this possum is
just one of many animals around
Australia seeing its habitat go up in
smoke Australia's native fauna and flora
are accustomed to bush fires but this
season has been unprecedented landscapes
usually left unscathed have been
decimated on the new south wales south
coast this native bird has been brought
in for treatment at the local wildlife
park it's called a kora Wang and its
wings are singed and broken people
presume birds are gonna be okay because
they just sort of fly off but like we
said where would they fly to and what
foods going to be around just about
everything that sort of is a ground well
err of some description would really
struggle because it you go and have a
look now and there's there's no
understory to the to the bush in the
surrounding area so I don't think there
was a species that was exempt field
teams are going into the bush looking
for injured animals and assessing the
areas affected by the fires Australia's
famed plants and animals are a strong
part of the country's identity many of
its species are found nowhere else in
the world and the extent of the damage
isn't clear yet this bushfire season has
burned through millions of hectares of
land destroying the habitats of many
native animals some of these forests
will take decades to regenerate and
others may never recover some plants
like eucalyptus trees have adapted to
survive fires but the combination of
drought and extreme temperatures raises
concerns about even those species before
these fires we're already in severe
drought so populations of many different
species would have been in decline and
and already you know at low levels prior
to the fires these baby kangaroos or
Joey's are orphans they're now in care
but for many animals who do make it out
of the fires they soon face other
problems they are also now really
vulnerable because they're coming to
roadside and to homes that have some
grass in order to eat and then they're
then they're vulnerable to cats and dogs
and enter car crash for those who do
survive it's a long and pain
for road to recovery Jessica Washington
al-jazeera Mogo Australia